What kind of guy is the other knight?
Well, he's the only one besides Otsutsuki who can kill me.
Do it quickly. There's no
one else there. Who is that guy again? Are you my
sister's new guy?
Before you know it,
Code.
Don't attack him. Hey, this
guy rides around a lot.  It's comfortable, come on down.
But you promise not to jump on someone you've never met before. You must be
serious, right? As for your
sister, I
'll kill you if you leave me alone. That person is just a
friend.
No matter how you look at it, I'm my type.  Isn't that right?
[Music] Don't
come over here. You'll be killed. I'll just
wait for 10 seconds. You have to run.
If the modified humans get out, I'm
ordered to kill them immediately. Did they find me? There's
no need to do anything.
Okay, just look carefully and we'll
do it all at once.
[Music] [
Music] Idiot,
what's
going on? [Music] [Music] Is it a reflection? The opponent's attack is the
result of the moment the opponent has murderous intent.  He
reacts even more strongly to strong murderous intent.
You should be careful too. Code. This guy is
pretty dangerous.
[Applause] I'd like to
introduce you to my other knight and
younger brother,
Damon.
[music]